bonsoir bonsoir à tous les deux soirs
alors vous êtes ici donc pour la sortie
évidemment de blueberry dans vincent est
l'acteur principal et ian le réalisateur
alors c'est un film dont on a beaucoup
parlé les rumeurs les plus folles ont
couru à son sujet d'abord on a dit que
c'est un notable financièrement ensuite
on a dit que l'équipe était complètement
dépassés complètement défoncé la sortie
a été retardée il ya eu des problèmes
avec ugc qui après une première
projection a menacé de refuser le film
le film a été remontée de 3 heures 45
ans en 120 minutes bref enfin y avait un
côté sur ce film comme ça déjà un peu
légendaire avant même qu'il sorte un
petit peu genre les amants du pont-neuf
du fameux leos carax ou même le film de
terry gilliam sur don quichotte ou même
le don quichotte d'orson welles qui
n'est jamais sorti non plus il y avait
quelque chose autour de ce film est
enfin blueberry et là et les 11 février
il sort dans 600 salles alors evian
l'aventuré sans nous était plus simple
si vous étiez contenter d'adapter la
bande dessinée blueberry telle qu'elle a
été écrite par charlie et giroud
j'imagine en un mot en un mot
honnêtement oui oui très bien quand on
voit le film on se rend compte qu'on
fait beau berry la bande dessinée au
départ c'est en fait un déclencheur d'un
processus créatif vous avez déclaré jan
kounen on va pas trahir ça on va créer
autre chose vous vous acheter les droits
d'une bande dessinée mais pour pas la
trahir vous faites autre chose en deux
mots
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que jean giraud
c'est aussi mouiller bus sénateurs de
l'incal c'est un artiste qui voyagent
dans les mondes imaginaires qui est
passionné de chamanisme et donc si jean
giraud était pas moins but j'aurais pas
fait ce film et je lui proposais
justement de l'amener dans cette
dimension donc quelque part de faire
l'album de blueberry dessiné par moebius
d'accord alors on n'est pas avec steam
on s'évite une erreur de charlier et
giro alors il ya le lieutenant blueberry
qui s'appelle publiquement vous verrez
d'ailleurs s'appelle mike blueberry et
la plupart du temps il s'appelle mike
tout simplement donc il est marshall à
palau mytho ils tentent de faire régner
l'ordre et la jusque là c'est à peu près
conforme à la bd à deux détails près
c'est à dire que vous êtes cage une
serre que vous venez de louisiane
l'accent français vous avez fait ça
ouais c'était en fait quand le yen est
revenu me voir avec avec thomas langmann
pour me proposer le film j'ai d'abord
pensé que c'était parce qu'il trouvait
pas l'acteur américain et que je me
sentais je me suis je vais pas faire de
bouche trou et
en fait je le dis tout moi je veux bien
mais il faudrait qu'on retravaille
quelques petites choses sur les
personnages pour que ça soit enfin que
le fait que je joue le rôle mois soit
plutôt un avantage d'une part et donc on
a retravaillé des trucs et très vite
cette idée de faire de blueberry un mec
qui venait à l'origine de louisiane est
arrivé mais en fait ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'après a fait ce
choix là on s'est rendu compte que
effectivement un dans la bd ils venaient
du sud était louis de louisiane deuxième
deuxième différence avec la bande
dessinée blueberry a été élevé par les
par les indiens et ça c'est très
important c'est un détail qui a son
importance puisqu'il est complètement
entre deux civilisations celle de palau
mito cas civilisation moderne
matérialiste violente et puis de la
civilisation des indiens donc il a un
petit peu entre les deux comme ça et ils
essayent de réconcilier finalement de
ces deux civilisations il essaie de
réconcilier les deux civilisations mais
il essaye aussi de se réconcilier lui
même avec les deux les civilisations et
larmes un vrai problème d'identité pour
réconcilier ces deux mondes blueberry
par la recherche de lui même à travers
une quête initiatique aidés par des
chats mans avec il a grandi donc le
pitch on peut dire que c'est un western
chamanique en fait en fait le chamanisme
c c'est un art de guérison en fait donc
le chaman c'est c'est quelqu'un qui vit
dans une autre réalité et qui est don et
dont l'arrêt de guérir et de
rééquilibrer les individus donc mike est
un très bon sujet pour ça parce qu'il
est assez déséquilibré et c'est aussi le
voyage vers d'autres perceptions c'est
une autre forme de façon de voir le
monde
le chamanisme c'est un art millénaire
ancestrale je pense même ses antérieurs
aux religions enfin on le dit que ses
intérieurs aux religions et que c'est
encore pratiquée dans certains endroits
du monde c'est méconnu nous dans notre
culture on reconnaît qu'à une forme de
science de l'esprit de recherche
intérieure quand on parle du tibet du
travail des moines de la méditation mais
on on n'a pas encore cette approche sur
ces gens qui vivent dans la jungle est
qui et qui sont qui font des recherches
de ce même domaine alors on pense qu'en
tant quand on voit ce film on pense aux
grands films des années 70 pas moi en
tous les cas j'étais en pays connu parce
que ça fait penser un peu à 2001 odyssée
de l'espace à la traversée comme ça à
travers des effets vers vers vers
l'ailleurs vers l'infini les espaces
infinis et or ce qui est extraordinaire
dans le film c'est que c'est du cinéma
non figuratif et ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez nouveau c'est à dire que quand
il ya les visions que blueberry à après
avoir bu la la décoction des chamans n'a
finalement on voit des choses qu'on voit
quand on prend de l'acide convoi quand
on prend des champignons hallucinogènes
et c'est retranscrit sur un écran de
cinéma mais ça je crois que c'est la
première fois qua non je dirais que
c'est ce type d'expérience c'est sur
l'essence à un moment donné il faut il
faut essayer de non pas de regarder et
d'essayer de comprendre vraiment avec
son esprit ce que ça veut dire essayer
de le ressentir avec des images la
musique et le son c'est le voyage
intérieur ça a bien relancé les ventes
d'acide ce truc
je suis pas sûr il faut bien comprendre
deux choses c'est que le chamanisme par
exemple ces nounous ce nous nous sommes
les primitifs de notre culture quand
nous allons vers les psychotropes parce
qu on le fait de manière festive et on
oublie tout on se perd un peu et on en
gare de rien faut penser qu' ils font ça
pour soigner c'est quand même un
mystérieux et donc quand vous prenez ces
plantes avec les indiens ça se passe
dans le noir général vous venez vous
faire soigner pour tous les indiens est
en tout cas ça je le savais pas que
festive c'est que ça génère des frayeurs
effectivement quand vous dites qu'on ait
des primitifs par rapport à eux c'est un
peu le côté de little big man du film
c'est à dire que little big man c'était
un film pour la première fois je crois
qu'on voyait des indiens on admettez que
les indiens avaient plus de
connaissances que nous sur le plan
spirituel alors vous allez profiter tous
les deux des repérages pour vous initier
quand même un peu au chamanisme vous
avez là un moment toi tu es parti dedans
quand même non on a dit kounen il est
parti en vrille quand même en revenant
d'un repérage vous avez décidé quand
même d'arrêter de cinéma bah oui c'est
vrai qu'à un moment donné on va chercher
l'inspiration comme un artiste en disant
avec respect et puis en fait dans ce
genre de sujet moment donné vous voulez
retourner c'est plus du cinéma yann donc
vous vous avez pratiqué donc là-bas en
amazonie lors des repérages et vincent
aussi si vous aviez fait une petite
psychanalyse ya quelques années mais pas
très pas très forte et puis d'un seul
coup c'est la grande claque dont
j'imagine que quand j'ai vu ian partir
comme ça de l'autre côté de la planète
pourra laisser émerger mais physiquement
là dedans pour alors que moi c'est resté
vraiment du domaine du livre et revenir
en me racontant des aventures absolument
incroyable il m'a proposé de venir
l'accompagner un moment et en fait je me
suis désisté deux fois parce que ça me
faisait peur et j'ai fini par y aller et
quand je suis revenu j'ai compris
pourquoi ça me faisait peur parce
qu'avec effectivement c'est terrifiant
c'est terrifiant puisque si tout d'un
coup le chamanisme et une manière de en
fait d'appréhender son inconscient en
étant éveillé il se trouve que
l'inconscience et des rêves mais c'est
aussi des cauchemars
d'où la nécessité d'un chaman avec soi
c'est à dire que la tendance à sortir la
substance du contexte hélas il faut là
c'est vraiment c'est le pilote et
l'avion avant de partir europ assistance
parce que
on a dit beaucoup de choses il
ya une phrase dans le film c'est
justement affronter peur et il sera qui
tu es dit le chameau et c'est une phrase
qui finalement résume résume tout à fait
le film alors vous ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que les visions
yann que vous avez eue vous avez dessiné
ou fait dessiner vous les avez soumises
à des chats mans qui les reconnaissent
qui les nomme et qui les corrige ça veut
dire que finalement quand on on prend ce
genre de substance et qu'on arrive à les
traduire visuellement
finalement ça rejoint d'autres visions
qui ont eu d'autres êtres humains quand
elle déjà codifiées si ça et puis une
expérience qu'ils avaient fait un moment
donné de donner ces substances 1
dix gènes a
désigné huit qui n'avait jamais rien vu
jamais vu de serpents et qui avait
dessiné un animal qui ne connaissais pas
qui était un serpent donc là c'est le
mystère et ça rejoint des archétypes
youm bien dans le bois l'acide par
l'inconscient collectif il faut et c'est
fort mais pendant le tournage quand vous
jouez les scènes à vous en buvez
vraiment détruire non c'est quelque
chose qui en fait c'est un psychotrope
qui est beaucoup trop puissante pour
pouvoir
pour pouvoir l'utiliser sur un plateau
cette saison avec de l'ecstasy en fait
parce que c'était trop fort non mais
disons qu'en fait c'est vrai que le fait
d'avoir été donc faire ses quelques
voyages dans la jungle et avoir
participé à des sessions chamanique
j'avais un j'avais de quoi puiser
fâcheuse j'avais un souvenir assez
précis de ce que c'était mais sur un
plateau il ya pas de plateau mais c'est
quand l'équipe
vous a pris pour des cinglés ce qui
s'est passé c'est que c'était la
première fois qu'on tournait une scène
tant qu'une séance de transe chamanique
pour le film et donc on a commencé je
crois vers 8 heures du soir et
commençait à faire nuit et puis on
tournait en tournée va en effet une
techno cren donc yann tourner autour de
moi avec la techno crenn et c'était bien
je crois ce qu'on vous ait été déjà été
déjà assez carré je crois que ça pouvait
faire la faire et je regardais le combo
donc le moniteur et je me disais mais
c'est bizarre il ya quelque chose qui
est trop en contrôle en fait si je me
rappelle bien dans ces moments là
j'étais vraiment complètement à l'envers
et il ya un moment il ya un photographe
qui est venu qui étaient toujours au
mauvais endroit sûr sur ce plateau et il
est venu un juste avant entre action et
entre moteur et action et ça m'a énervé
et j'ai eu un truc envers lui assez
violent et en fait ça m'a fait basculer
et à ce moment là ça commence à partir
dans un truc beaucoup plus étrange que
ce que j'avais fait depuis le début de
la soirée
et je sentais que ja ne s'arrêtait plus
de tournées dont je me suis dit
consciemment je me disais je suis dedans
je suis donc je suis dedans entre les
prises je voyais sève le pointeur qui ne
me regardait plus dans les yeux ouais je
faisais à la il ya un truc il ya un truc
qui a basculé qui commença à déraper ça
peut être pas mal est lui venu voir ce
moment là il m'a fait continuer comme ça
l'équipe nous prend pour des fous j'ai
explosé de rire
et malheureusement il ya plus de
pellicules mais on a tourné comme un
rempart contre le moment on a ri je
crois que l'équipe nous a pris encore un
peu plus pour des fous et c'était en
fait je ne savais pas tout ce qu'on a
l'air ajoutés par la suite les
producteurs ont eu peur ce jour là parce
qu'on a utilisé l'équivalent d'une
semaine de pellicule en une nuit on n'a
pas arrêté de tourner et on a fini de
tourner il devait être 5 heures du matin
le jour se levait je suis allé voir yann
je dis tu vois si ça avait été un autre
acteur très galéré pour lui expliquer et
madiba ce soir j'ai compris pourquoi
c'était toi qui devait faire le film et
là j'ai pris l'avion et je suis parti à
cannes pour présenter un autre univers
celui d' irréversible qui est pas très
sérieux aussi quand même c'était sérieux
donc oui c'était le passage d'un dans
cet univers où on était vraiment là où
on était il y avait rien et pas
d'électricité pas d'eau pas de téléphone
forcément on est monté les marches avec
monica bellucci donc et la presse et
tout le bordel que ça que ça que ça
suscite et le film en plus qui ne s'est
pas les gens indifférents loin c'est sûr
elle l'a vu blueberry monica bellucci
monica bellucci a vu boubers et bien sûr
et alors je vais je crois qu'il a
beaucoup apprécié les blogueurs il a vu
monica la voie et la voix vous dit en
parlant d'elle je comprends qu'elles
fassent autant rêver les hommes puisque
moi aussi elle elle me fait rêver oui
ouais
je pense à vous des fois je vous jure
c'est vrai mais je me dis je me dis ça
doit être terrible pour vous quand même
quand elle pas retourner à l'étranger
comme ça pendant trois mois et souvent
franchement on sérieusement en général
au même moment je suis en train de
tourner à l'étranger aussi vous savez il
faut mettre des bulles un peu ça mais de
l'air
la liberté c'est ce qui fait durer les
choses ouais le 31 mars un film de
frédéric schoendoerffer avec monica
bellucci et vous alors au départ après
six mois de blueberry vous ai dit je
vais pas retravailler sur l'expérience a
été a été trop forte et puis finalement
à ce moment là
monica est dans le projet de du film de
chan dorfer et vous dites je vais faire
le film parce que comme ça jeunes à bloc
pendant trois mois donc je me dis quand
même que quand je me fais du souci pour
vous j'ai un peu raison parce que quand
même quand vous pouvez la bloquer trois
mois les deux fronts temps comme c'est
gentil de vous inquiéter pour moi on est
vraiment parce que je trouve que vous
avez une femme sublime mais merci merci
vraiment et j'ai compris
c'est vrai
limite aucune chance
à dire allez changer cela
oui c'est vrai
y aller
rien à dire puisqu'on parle d'avenir on
va parler un petit peu aussi de ocean's
twelve qui est la suite de nos chaînes
et les veines avec clooney brad pitt
julia roberts et andy garcia
vous allez revenir d'hollywood après la
wii alors d'abord on tourne par
hollywood on tourne dans l'europe ah
ouais ouais
pourquoi je le fais pas
écouté
thunder bay regret vient me voir à
cannes il me dit j'ai vu irréversible
j'ai vu sur mes lèvres j'ai vu la haine
j'ai un job pour toi je dit écoute
steven
je t'aime bien non mais j'ai dit
pourquoi pas évidemment et puis quand il
me fait lire le script et je me rends
compte que ce n'est pas de méchants
français bien au contraire il faut pas
devenir français de liant au delà pas
comme charles boyer je ne deviens pas le
français de hollywood et qui plus est le
rôle qui me propose c'est la plus grand
cambrioleur du monde ouais je voulais je
vous dis ça se prend ça se prend mais
vous êtes assez solide par rapport aux
tentations financière un beau dit que
finalement si on a assez de blé pour
bouffer faut pas faire n'importe quoi
pour l'argent vous gérez votre carrière
plutôt plutôt bien quand même à sa merci
en menant deux fois vraiment sympa parce
que j'avais pressenti à votre femme
l'accord
en fait je ne suis pas du tout en un set
mais je joue j'essaye de faire un peu
plus d'argent que le juste pour manger
j'aime beaucoup voyager etc mais disons
que je ne pense que coûte et pour faire
un film on fait un film il faut le
sortir sortir un fiel c'est ce que je en
train de faire en ce moment ici ce soir
est ce que j'ai fait depuis un mois avec
la presse les trucs et machins etc c'est
exténuant et je pense que c'est très
mauvais pour la santé morale et je me
dis qu'il faut pas trop en faire en fait
ça se limite à ça c'est à dire qu'il
vaut mieux être vous dire que c'était
disparaître un petit peu trop longtemps
et revenir avec des projets aussi
marquant que celui qui a réalisé yann
plutôt que d'enchaîner des trucs pour
pour quoi faire je crois que j'ai
l'impression déjà en chaîne ou alors
parce qu'ils ont peur de disparaître
complètement ou alors parce que ils ont
besoin d'amasser quelque chose pour je
sais pas quoi faire parce qu'ils ont
peur de manquer ça voilà ce crois que
les gens ont peur de mon grand il vient
d'un compas tourné pendant des années
donc effectivement mais j'ai eu la
chance d'être gâtés très tôt puisque
j'ai attaqué assez vite avec des films
que je que j'apprécie beaucoup je pense
à la haine même à métis donc en fait je
suis pas inquiet c'est peut-être ouais
c'est peut-être ça ouais alors justement
on parle de deux métis
kassovitz je les faire la ville donne
bébébiz d'après le bouquin de dantec ça
vous gêne pas dans les déclarations
enfin vous savez sûrement mais j'imagine
que kassovitz aussi les déclarations de
dantec sur le bloc identitaire
parce que là maintenant quand me
soutient ouvertement alors ce qu'il a
vraiment dit ça j'ai pas suivi en fait
il a répondu c'est un problème
effectivement c'est un problème je dois
dire que j'explique à mes amis
téléspectateurs donc maurice dans le
tech qui était un écrivain chez
gallimard plutôt plutôt plutôt
intéressante walter intéressant qui d'un
seul coup commence à partir un peu comme
houellebecq quand il avait déclaré que
l'islam était la religion la plus con du
monde derrière houellebecq maintenant
fréquentent les raéliens donc c'est vrai
que ça commence à venir visant et dantec
pareil dantec café des bouquins plutôt
bien d'un seul coup il se met en liaison
avec le bloc identitaire qui est
finalement ce qui a remplacé unité
radicale telle unité radicale c'est le
mec a voulu tuer chirac au 14 juillet
quand même et tout à fait dantec tient
des propos mais terrifiant sur sur les
arabes sur les musulmans écoutez je sais
pas quoi vous dire ce que je sais c'est
que j'ai lu un scénario maintenant il ya
un an qui pourrait faire un film est
vraiment extraordinaire donc maintenant
je sais pas où ça en est le film est
annoncé j'ai pas lu les que la
déclaration en question mais je vais les
hyènes article dans le point cette
semaine vous garderez vous
vous pensez à quoi là je me dis merde
pourquoi parce que je pensais échapper à
ce genre de trucs
ouais
vous dites quoi le matin quand vous
regardez dans le miroir je me dis bon
encore une qui commence on n'a qu'à se
dire qu'on a de la chance vous auriez
aimé ressembler à cliquer ans vous étiez
petit petit
petit spider man quelle insulte qui vous
a fait le plus mal
attendez que j'ai pas de conneries
ça fait un petit moment en ont peut-être
que c'est des trucs là que je lis en ce
moment dans la presse quand il ya des
gens qui comprennent pas le film ça
m'énerve moi j'ai vu que des bons
papiers sur le film il ya eu un truc qui
m'a énervé les gens dit il ya un mec qui
a écrit que le film était chip et je les
prie pour moi quand avez vous pleuré
pour la dernière fois dans blueberry way
dans une scène mais pour le rôle oui oui
pour le roi mais sinon on devrait aller
aux jeux réponse que je vois un haga
il songe auriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
un peu moins d'ego ouais ouais ben ouais
c'est vrai
qu'elle est le péché qui vous tente le
plus
values cuivre avec ta fabre goethe
qui avez vous le plus envie d'épater
déjà moi ouais ouais quelle est la
dernière chose que vous faites le soir
avant de vous coucher une petite
branlette
d'ego qui pensent qu'à toi
même
les gens le comprennent mal cheveux le
mec il avec monica bellucci ça c'est
qu'il ya un problème énorme vincent que
pourriez-vous dire de plus négatif sur
vous qui vient de faire ses vraies
bonnes réponses
qu'est ce que je pourrais dire de plus
négatif sur moi
là tout de suite tu es vraiment à chier
dans blueberry et
il faudrait pas d'accord ça me fait
plaisir
si votre vie était à refaire vous
changeriez quoi
pour le moment pas grand chose
en même temps c'est vrai quand on voit
vos films le peu de femmes c'est vrai
qu'on se dit dans le fond il n'y a pas
de ça il ya deux mois je voyais bien des
problèmes
1 il ya bien des points faibles il les
trouva rien tu le sais bien ah non moi
j'ai un gros
qu'avez-vous fait vincent que nous ne
sachions pas alors justement au
restaurant la kws et menti durant cette
interview bien sûr que non et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus